el asma es una enfermedad pulmonar que
inflama y estrecha las vías
respiratorias
normalmente a medida que usted inhala el
aire circula libremente a través de la
tráquea y luego a través de grandes
conductos llamados bronquios a través de
conductos más pequeños llamados
bronquiolos y finalmente hacia pequeños
sacos llamados alveolos
y pequeños vasos sanguíneos llamados
capilares rodean los alveolos
el oxígeno del aire que respira pasa los
capilares y luego el dióxido de carbono
del cuerpo sale de los capilares y se
dirige a los alveolos para que los
pulmones puedan deshacerse de él cuando
usted exhale
los bronquiolos se expanden cuando el
aire es cálido y húmedo y está libre de
agentes irritantes y sustancias que
causan alergias denominadas alérgenos
cuando el aire es frío o seco o contiene
agentes irritantes o alérgenos los
bronquios se contraen
si usted tiene asma sus vías
respiratorias se inflaman y se hinchan
con frecuencia
algunas sustancias pueden hacer que las
vías respiratorias inflamadas reaccionen
de forma aún más exagerada dando lugar a
un ataque de asma los desencadenantes de
los ataques de asma son ligeramente
diferentes en cada persona pero por lo
general incluyen agentes irritantes y
alérgenos del exterior como polen humo
contaminación y clima frío
agentes irritantes y alérgenos de
interiores como moho
caspa de animales ácaros del polvo y
excrementos de cucaracha
y alimentos que causan alergia como
pescado mariscos huevos maníes y soja
y condiciones como infecciones
respiratorias
estrés emociones fuertes y ejercicio
los síntomas de un ataque de asma
incluyen tos resuellos dificultad para
respirar y opresión en el pecho
durante un ataque de asma también
conocido como broncoespasmo los músculos
que rodean las vías respiratorias se
tensionan y la pared de las vías
respiratorias se inflaman aún más las
vías respiratorias también producen un
moco espeso que las estrecha aún más lo
que dificulta la respiración
si usted tiene asma su médico le puede
recetar medicamentos para reducir la
inflamación de las vías respiratorias la
contracción de los músculos que rodean
las vías respiratorias o la secreción de
moco en las vías respiratorias
durante un ataque de asma es posible que
necesite usar un medicamento de rescate
de acción corta llamado bronco dilatador
este medicamento hace que los músculos
de las vías respiratorias se relajen
rápidamente y alivia los síntomas en
cuestión de minutos
dado que no hay cura para el asma el
objetivo es evitar que usted tenga un
ataque de asma mediante el uso de
medicamentos de control antiinflamatorio
de acción prolongada
si los toma todos los días se reducirá
la inflamación de las vías respiratorias
haciendo que las vías respiratorias sean
menos sensibles a los factores
desencadenantes de los ataques de asma